who's gonna take care of this family
when i'm gone
i thought your mama was gonna be all
right
be happy do good
but she got tore up around here she just
up and quit
she just stopped trying
i know
i could have done better
but you you got to decide
you want to be somebody or not
oh boy that's powerful stuff from glenn
close's mamaw in the new netflix movie
hillbilly elegy it's based on the 2016
memoir of the same name
by jd vance it's about growing up in
appalachia vance
is an executive producer on the film
version which
is directed by the legendary there he is
ron howard one of the good guys in
hollywood in the movie
as in life vance's family grapples with
financial hardship and addiction
jd vance and ron howard join us this
morning good to see you both guys i was
so excited we were so excited to talk to
you today
welcome welcome thank you i read the
book to you
if only this way i can't wait till we
can be in the same room again ronnie i
really can't
jd i read the book back in the day i
looked at the movie again ron howard i
look at everything that you do and i
want to start with you about this
particular movie because you said
you were drawn to it because it's a
family story and you relate to it and i
think when i heard ron howard relates to
this story how but it is a very
universal story
for a lot of people start us off with
that
well my roots go back to a small
town and agricultural rural oklahoma
um cheryl's family louisiana and
uh agricultural wisconsin so uh
you know i've been looking for a while
for a story
that um you know set in set in that
environment in a contemporary
way when brian grazer my partner at
imagine was the first to read hillbilly
elegy and i think he met jd as well and
we began talking about it and when i
read it and spoke to jd
you know i felt that there was a really
interesting contemporary story
here um a truthful family drama
i was drawn to that it i also felt it
was an interesting sort of emotional
rescue and survival story that really
celebrated the women in his life
especially
the matriarch played by glenn mama and
by the way
i i called my great-grandmother ma'am it
wasn't just me that was that's what
everyone
uh called her i didn't even know i
thought that was her specific nickname i
didn't know until i read jd's book
uh that it was uh it was sort of a
regional cultural thing well mama
jd was quite the character you tell us
about her lack of knowledge she taught
you does not mean lack of intelligence
you said you come from a family that
says that believes never speak at a
reasonable volume when screaming will do
that if a fight gets to a little too
intense it's okay to slap and punch as
long as a man doesn't hit first and it's
okay to be insulting and hurtful to your
partner if all
else fails take the kids and the dogs to
a local motel
i mean you opened up a whole different
world for people
and i thought it was interesting how it
resonated in 2016
do you feel that it still resonates
today
well i think certainly the response to
the movie and so many of the emails and
messages that i've gotten since the
movie comes out came out suggested it
still resonates
i think a lot of people attach to
specific political significance but
you know these problems of family
struggle of addiction and resilience i
really do think are timeless because we
we still have an addiction problem in
this country just like we did in 2016.
and so i think for a lot of the audience
it does still resonate
yeah and ron ron the cast that you got
glenn close
we had her here was unrecognizable i'm
wondering jd what it's like for you to
see somebody playing you i thought both
the actors were great
tell us about what it's like for you to
see yourself being played on screen and
ron the cass that you put together
with amy adams and glenn yeah
what was it like it's so weird obviously
to see your st
yeah it's weird to see yourself on
screen and i think you know honestly the
weirdest thing for us was to see
glenn dressed up as mammal because he
was those who stick around to the end
and see the end credits realize she
really did look a lot like mamaw yeah it
was this really powerful experience when
we saw her for the first time and
you know mama's been dead for for over
10 years now and it's like this weird
way in which she had been brought back
to life
so it's it's bizarre it was fun we tried
just to roll with it and have a little
bit of fun with it but it's a
it's an experience i'd recommend for
those of you who get the chance to try
it
yeah i liked it hey guys it's tony
nicole i want i want to edge into
something a little bit uncomfortable
here and that's the fact that
some critics have really slashed and
burned this movie now i've seen bad
movies this is not one of them
and yet some of the same publications
that celebrated the book
are now coming out with hatchets for the
movie ron to you first and then i want
to hear from you as well jd what's going
on here
well it you know look it's always hard
to say and critics have a job which is
to
to see something run it through their
lens and write and
and uh and talk about it so i can't
argue with it
uh i do feel like that they're they're
they're looking
at uh you know political thematics
that uh that they may or may not
disagree agree with
uh that honestly aren't really reflected
or not front and center in this story
what i saw was a family drama
that could be very relatable yes
culturally specific
and if you're fascinated by that you
know i think you'll
you know i hope you find it interesting
if you if you're from the region
i hope you find it authentic because we
certainly that was our aim and that was
our that was our effort
but i felt that it was a bridge to
understanding that we're more alike than
we are different
ron howard and jd vance thank you both
very much hillbilly elegy is available
in select theaters and
on netflix